[Musique]
ils viennent d'afrique du sud des
comores de maurice et de madagascar avec
le même objectif se perfectionner en
langue française c'est au centre
international d'études pédagogiques au
tampon que ces quinze stagiaires vont
suivre une formation afin de renforcer
leurs compétences en langue française
parle où on va avec eux des étrangers
pour ça tout tout ce qui est paru aux
affaires étrangères ce sont des tâches
international et comme madagascar est un
pays francophone aussi négligés en même
temps où il est essentiel plus tôt il
est essentiel de savoir la langue les
langues étrangères au maximum pendant
quinze jours ils vont échanger et
pratiquer le français dans différentes
situations principalement dans le cadre
de leur profession
on va travailler sur le renforcement de
leurs compétences de communication
professionnelle que ce soit à l'oral les
participations des conversations ou
prise de parole en public pour les
autres et à l'écrit aussi bien les
emails que le courrier administratif que
les rapports soutenue par le conseil
départemental
cet échange vise à développer le
programme d'appui à la francophonie dans
la zone océan indien
ces stagiaires accueilleront bientôt des
volontaires d'assistant français à
l'étranger
recruté à la réunion
[Musique]